venons en ce début des vacances au
tourisme qui fait rêver le tourisme de
luxe une industrie qui génère des
milliards d'euros du tourisme 5 étoiles
à cannes jean jacques dufour jean
lemelin
si j'étais riche vous rattraper les gros
poissons la clientèle du tourisme de
luxe elle qui dépensent des milliers
d'euros pour faire des ronds dans l'ô
canada s'est jamais occupé et je dirais
même qu'elle est pour les appétits
cannes c'est mieux que la riviera
italienne
c'est mieux que la riviera espagnol et
c'est pas trop cher si vous voulez payer
- et vous n'avez qu'à aller dans une
tente
ces touristes qui préfèrent les palaces
au camping ne représente que 3% des 700
millions de voyageurs internationaux
c'est peu mais leur pouvoir d'achat est
énorme d'ailleurs et toujours à propos
d'argent
il paraît que le nombre de milliardaires
a augmenté effectivement il ya de plus
en plus de riches la statistique récente
prouve qu'il y à 11% de milliardaires en
plus en 2003 par rapport à 2002 c'est
très encourageant pour tous les métiers
du luxe et ça nous promet de très belles
années très encourageant surtout quand
on sait combien ce genre de vacancier
peut dépenser par jour
il tourne autour de 12 mille euros par
jour 12000 euros par jour y passer des
vacances hier suivre ça fait des
vacances de qualité
après les émirs les nouveaux riches
russes la croisette attend maintenant
l'arrivée des chinois et des indiens
enfin disons plutôt des chinois et des
indiens qui ont réussi dans les affaires
ce titre on a investi 1 5 million
d'euros sur la plage sur lequel nous
sommes en ce moment et dans le hall et
la construction de nouvelles suites au
martinez plus de 12 millions d'euros ces
trois dernières années
comme vous le savez on n'attrape pas les
mouches avec du vinaigre avec du
vinaigre peut-être pas mais avec des
langoustines au caviar il paraît que
c'est du billard
ah mais c'est évident c'est évident
omaha omaha je pense à meilleures
cuisines du monde
on a là une vraie cuivre ecully de
région qu'aucun neuf pays n'at on va à
travers le monde
donc c'est notre grande richesse
culturelle c'est évident de quoi ouvrir
luxe à une définition
le luxe c'est un très beau décor c'est
surtout le service saas est un des
choses les plus importantes on peut les
chouchouter le tourisme de luxe est une
grosse affaire 150 milliards de dollars
de recettes annuelles
c'est un beau gâteau un gâteau que les
professionnels du secteur se dispute
avec âpreté né dans une compétition
féroce si vous voulez mondialement c'est
pas une compétition simple puisque
toutes les villes qui veulent attirer
justement les gros poissons elles mêmes
ou si c'est de faire des événements
essaie d'attirer les gens c'est pas
facile c'est pas facile et surtout rien
n'est définitif ce qu'on peut dire eh
oui là comme ailleurs le vent peut
tourner si j'étais riche des yeux 2
non